I asked my 59 month old
my 108 month old
and my 144 month old
what they'd like to eat today
and they all agreed on pizza
I suspected that they were quite hungry
because they were quite grumpy and
also quite lethargic
but I knew they wouldn't mind if I took a
further four halfs of an hour
for myself to do a quick full glam before
getting started on my dough
and this dough is a family secret
my ancestors brought this recipe with them to Aotearoa on the Aurora
which was one of the first migrant ships to come here in the 1800s
and this recipe definitely did not come from the Dish website
I lightly floured my surface and then began to take out
any passive aggression that I might have towards my life on the dough
and once it was as dense and fluffy as I am
then I popped it into an oiled bowl and set it aside so it could rise
and then it was time to get started on my pizza sauce
and I find this process oddly cathartic
because it reminds me of the lobotomy I got two years ago
best decision that was ever made for me
I foraged these tomatoes by hand from the shores of Muriwai Beach
and combine them with these baby onions
which I found at the local market
which we call Woolies
I pulverised the papercorns with the same methodology
they used on my frontal lobe
and then I added a few extra things
in an attempt to make these tomatoes not taste like pure fkn cardboard
I added some herbs
which I pilfered from my neighbour's garden through a gap in the fence
because I'm not actually
allowed to leave the property without the accompaniment of a man
then I combined the sauce
which is always my favourite part for some weird reason
then it was time to get started on our mozzarella cheese
and everybody knows that mozzarella cheese taste best with fresh milk
so I decided to head down to the garden and get some
I also decided to pick up a few fresh eggs for breakfast tomorrow
while I was there
homesteading has been the most rewarding
experience I could have ever wished for
and our garden has never been so bountiful
blessed be the fruit
I started by heating my raw
untreated milk to temperature
and then adding exactly 7 tablespoons of homemade vinegar
and I find the best way to make your own vinegar is just to wring out
your husband's socks after he's had a long
hard day sitting on his ass
once the curd is separated from the whey
you just squeeze the curd until the excess water is removed
and I know it is very physically taxing work
but I do find I get extra grip strength when I
just think about the patriarchy
and then we heat the whey again
careful not to go past 69 degrees
because my brother
father and husband have all forbidden me from using that number
and I'm not sure why
but I trust that they have my best interest at heart
and then plunge your two balls into ice cold water
and I promise they won't shrink
and then 423 and a half minutes after I first started
it was time to give my dough a second knead
and at this point
the children were whinging that they were starving
and I told them not to be so dramatic
and that - like Christmas-
dinner was coming
I took my cheesy balls out of the cold water
before thinly slicing them and confirming that the mozzarella was indeed
squeaky and dense
which is funny enough
exactly how they describe me on my hospital intake form
right before I had that procedure
which I can't quite remember whether or not I told you about
my memory is not what it used to be
then I assembled the one pizza
which took me literally all day to make
but it's okay
because I'm from the leisure class
so I don't actually have to do any real domestic chores
we have people for that
at this point
I was so excited to share my hard work with the children
but I thought first I'd have a quick taste test
to ensure quality control
and as they observed me
they decided they no longer felt like pizza
and they actually wanted chicken nuggets
so back to the kitchen I go